[Music]
foreign
itai beck thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders
thank you happy to be here very great to
have you i visited the offices
and not so long ago to do a tldr video
with you
about a very cool startup and i'd love
to dive
straight into b2b marketing uh
you know almost everybody that that's
around me we
all feel like we're all all of a sudden
experts on b2c marketing and how do you
sell products to consumers because
that's what most of us do
but you have a different a a different
skill set
and you're focused on marketing to
businesses which is
very different tell me about it it is
it is uh you know when you think about
uh the
you when you start with the customers
right the customer that oh how do they
buy
the consumer buys by you know kind of
making a quick decision or maybe not
so quick necessarily but it's a personal
decision
uh we're uh i mean kind of the most
complicated you think about the consumer
maybe it's uh between the person and the
spouse yeah
but that's as far as it goes when it's a
business buy
you have a whole committee to convince
uh it could be a formal committee it
could be informal committee
and that process is not easy there's
risk there's rewards
people use that kind of processes to
become
kind of advance their careers people
take risks uh
in in that in that process because what
happens if i
kind of stood up for something and it
doesn't work
eventually then i'm gonna pay and so on
so it's much more complex decision
making process that's yeah
to begin with which means that as uh
bonds we need to
market not to specific people only but
also to
specific accounts so what i'm hearing
from you
on a high level while b2c marketing may
have different tactics for impulsive
buying
and individual decision making when
you're looking at businesses who are
purchasing
it's much more complicated because you
have to convince a lot of moving parts
and it's also much longer it's not just
you know a a buy now button
it's a process that you have to go
through it is a process
i mean well it depends on what is that
you buy right in some cases
there is uh you know there are some
deals which are pretty straightforward
and simple to buy
there is a whole economy like a cloud
based sales economy that yeah
sure built on the idea that that the
buying
process in the enterprise in the
businesses is
not as traditional you don't have to use
so many people
but as it becomes more complex if you
buy a larger
something for a larger amount and it
influences uh confirm more
or deeper i would say business processes
then it goes back to the older days uh
but you'll find you know in uh
company i i think you know one of the
early examples of that were
uh with dropbox even much before that
salesforce right
when salesforce started the cloud
business somebody even called that cloud
back then
uh back in 2002 or three then people
started buying that for like a small
team of five people and so on and then
eventually it became a an enterprise buy
so it depends on what is it that you
sell
and who do you sell to uh but for the
most part if you are selling a large
uh kind of a deal it's complex and and
does need this
uh more traditional process
no that makes a lot of sense so i'd love
to sort of go back and and learn a
little bit more about you and
what are some of your experiences and
how did you get to build a startup
that's doing really interesting things
on personalized marketing for specific
accounts
so you know i i used to work uh in
israel
you know right after my military service
uh that was like 10 years old
10 years uh long the whole the whole
process
uh i i joined the startup in the area of
your site communications and uh
that was required by the june financial
process and i hope throughout that
process
was telling to service providers i
joined
networks yeah here in sunnyvale and um
and throughout that process i kind of uh
experienced a lot of
those buying processes where you need to
kind of uh
have a way for marketing and sales
together to message properly to each and
every one of those accounts because
when it is a very uh kind of uh
sophisticated buying committee then
every scenario is somewhat different
and therefore you cannot sell the same
thing to everybody you have to be very
clear about understanding what is your
customer what do they want
uh what's their business problem how
they want to solve it everyone thinks
they're
they're very unique yeah even though you
can find some patterns
and and then come from one thing led to
the other and you know because i i spent
like
10 years ish between uh or maybe
seven years uh between the startup and
then
and then the juniper and and all
together it kind of uh
it accumulated and at some point i got
it that you know there's a big missing
component here
uh the idea of trying to use the same
b2c
strategies and tactics and the same
processes and systems
on a complex b2b environment just
doesn't work and there's a room for
innovation
that's kind of what led me together with
my partner david brookman to start
uh follows back in 2013.
wow okay so tell me about follows what
is
this strategy behind better marketing
for b2b
uh it's pretty clear it's about
personalization uh
what the the same the same tactics or
strategy that has been
used by uh in b2c for so many years
you know when you go into these days you
go to starbucks right
then you buy a very very specific coffee
right yeah
you have just a specific uh flavor and
and you can do it from their app and
you're gonna
pick it up right right the same thing
happens in the business right uh but
it's not treated well
so ideally that that you would keep on
marketing to
other businesses using a very broad
generic
message it just falls flat everyone is
receiving tons of emails and seen so
many ads and uh
and we just don't respond to that but if
you can
personalize your message from marketing
and sales
way before sales are in the picture
right from your website from the
ads from anything everything is
personalized to every visitor from every
account
then you are uh much more likely to get
a response and that's what we do
because it sounds like you're right
marketing is all about storytelling
and your ability to tell a story that
conforms to the other
to the person who's in front of you and
each of those people especially in b2b
is different right every company has a
different need and you're helping
brands tell their story in a
personalized way based on
you understanding the account that
you're trying to target
correct correct yes it's a it's a kind
of a
combination of data where you can
bring in the data about your accounts uh
their their confirmed graphics the size
the geography
the i would say the uh you know the
vertical
yeah all kinds of stuff like that but
also
what is it that they're looking for and
then you combine all that together
you can do the math quickly it becomes
thousands of different permutations and
and if you don't have a
simple way to cater to that uh you know
enormous number of different
permutations then you end up doing a
pretty generic
work which uh is less and less effective
so if i'm a new brand that wants to
market through follows
and because i want to reach 11 different
potential accounts on 11 different
verticals
what is my interaction with you how do i
get started
on this process well
um you know anyone that wants to kind of
start uh working with us
of course can start starting our website
uh yeah
for uh discussion and then we'll take it
from there usually what we'll do is
we'll kind of work with
with our customers to identify
you know what are their needs what are
they looking for and try to build with
them a program
uh we will uh sell them kind of licenses
for our
platform but we can also provide some
services to go to
this process most of our customers would
start with targeting say
10 10 20 50 top accounts and then pretty
quickly after that scale it to a hundred
and a thousand and then we have
even some customers that are marketing
to thousands of accounts
and each one of them is receiving
something different so there's a lot
is there a lot of creativity going to
play here do you have a people that work
full-time free that are you know their
job is to think
creatively how do i tell your story to
fit these different accounts so usually
we
partner with
the marketers on the other end uh which
have a lot of creative
ideas and they have the subject matter
expertise we bring our
kind of our own own services we many
times bring
very creative agencies uh to the uh
to the process and then together it
becomes a very successful i can say that
everyone is so successful but many of
them
are very successful so and how much of
this is technology in the back end so
there's obviously the human aspect of
of of coming and and doing all these
communications
is there a lot of technology that goes
into play to be able to really
understand the other accounts
and how to and how to tailor the story
for them
for sure this is a healthy combination i
mean there's no
there's no tool out there that would
actually work without the the human
uh creativity and ingenuity uh
but but even if you have creativity in
ingenuity and
you don't have the platform to scale
that then
you're very limited and since it's a
healthy combination between the two
no no that makes a lot of sense so what
are some of your you know earned
secrets over the over your time it
follows
about b2b marketing that you know you
feel very confident about
that the rest of the world might not
still know yet
yeah i i don't know if these are if
these are secrets i think
it's it's the fundamentals uh the
fundamentals are
kind of really understand very well your
market
uh understand very well your customers
and
and put a lot of uh kind of uh effort
on working together between marketing
and sales right that's
it's hard uh many kinds of marketing
and sales organizations uh don't work
that well
between them and then the result is is
much
uh is much worse than if you can
actually crack that
so working well in ahead of time uh
kind of uh combining the efforts uh
understanding the expectations working
together that that's essential
understanding the customers is essential
um being creative trying different
things being
iterative and these days you know
especially when we're all
under this kind of siege if you like uh
we all have to try different things and
and things change rapidly
uh in in accounts these days especially
so you have to be very much uh
connected to or not connected but but
committed to agility
uh the the days of working uh on
campaigns for like six months and then
trying it for another six months and
then making another
another next year these days are over
right you have
now to be able to respond in a few days
try something for a couple weeks if it
doesn't work
uh ditch it and try something new and
even if it works you try it
in other ways or make it more
sophisticated you have to integrate a
lot
uh it's a new term to new age wow now
that i mean that's
it's crazy to think that you know 10
years ago even
less than 10 years ago people would
would spend you know six months on a
marketing campaign and come up with all
the strategy
only to find that all of a sudden the
world is changing and today like you're
saying
we have to be so adaptive that every day
we have to rethink okay what's the new
trend of the world
and you know especially what we're
seeing with covet 19 how everything is
just
turning upside down where are we moving
from here in terms of b2b marketing
let's say you know three four years down
the line
so so you know assuming that we all kind
of uh uh work well through
this crisis uh which i i believe is is
uh um
is enforcing or opening it it's become
it became a force in function
to those fundamentals that we all have
to change we it's a shakeup right
um all those uh traditional practices
where you were marketing uh broadly
and you have sales actually doing most
of the work these are done and over
and over 19 is just making it here and
now
need to change i believe that the next
generation of
b2b marketing must be personalized
there's no way around that
and uh and and brands and vendors
and vendors that would not adapt to that
will just not survive
yeah and is b2b marketing
so when you say accounts i just want to
clarify this
are these you know you know titles of
companies or these specific people
how granular are you getting with your
marketing right
so the simple way to think about it is
that you know it's a company to company
right
so your other your buyer is a company
and a company has
has a dna the company has a culture the
company has
uh behavior right uh in if you sell into
larger companies it's even more granular
because you have
a lot of different buying centers uh and
they're not and each one of them is an
account
right so so in the count is is kind of a
holistic um um
kind of a decision-making center and and
if you are able to identify what is that
bind center then
that's an encounter is there anything
that really surprised you since you
started this whole thing
so you thought that you knew about b2b
marketing through your experiences
and in in the valley and now that you're
running for those and you're seeing
you know thousands of these campaigns
you're learning you you learn you learn
something new
yeah i tend to say a lot in our business
that people have no imagination
not not in order to offend anybody but
what i
i find a lot is that the momentum the
sticking with what was working yesterday
uh is is is quite a lot quite hard to
change
people uh don't want to change that rock
a bit and
unless you actually show them how this
is going to work for them
right in a very visual fashion then they
would not uh be able to kind of most of
the people will not be able to
imagine how that might look like and
then it becomes a very
uh in perception it becomes a very risky
move and change uh so that that was
surprising to see that it's more
difficult than than uh than not but you
know
uh these days with account based
marketing being such a strong trend
in the market for the last two or three
years uh we are
all in all the vendors in this space we
are on on a
i think on a big train to kind of uh
disrupt the b2b
world no no it sounds fascinating you
know i'm
i'm more still in the in the tech world
and i don't know
anything about marketing but from from
what i saw back in your offices and what
you guys are doing and it makes so much
more sense
that these things have to be
personalized when you know people are
looking
and you know i'm getting now on linkedin
because of the titles that i have for
the different
jobs that i worked at i have all these
messages from different recruiters
and it's getting hard and i see that
it's getting harder and harder to tell
which ones are automated and which ones
are
personal and which is a little scary you
know when i see somebody who sent me
an obviously automated message and he's
he's talking about specific things that
i was
doing and it's it's a little bit you
know it's a little bit of a weird
experience
yeah i i think they you know kind of uh
uh good
marketing doesn't matter if it'd be too
stupid to be but good marketing is human
yeah it personally are not only
personalized and
uh we need to remember that we're not
here to kind of serve machines
machines are served are here to serve us
yeah and as long as we remember that
both as practitioners but also as buyers
i think we're good i love it itai before
we leave i'm gonna put you on the spot
uh one last time i want three words that
you think best describe you best
describe me three words that you would
describe yourself or
then maybe your co-founders would
describe you or some of your employees
yeah i think uh i would say
resilient innovative
um pusher i love it itai
thank you so so much best of luck with
fellows it sounds great
thank you very much have a wonderful day
stay safe